regarde Luas 3 ans a déjà des mimiques
de star emprunté à son célèbre père
Michel Paul narf à sa descente d'avion
il embrasse le maire de montlon ville où
il a fait son service militaire la
municipalité lui rend aujourd'hui un
grand hommage ça su bien qu' ch je
remercie énormément mon Luçon à travers
Monsieur le Maire qui me fait un grand
grand grand honneur je suis très très
ému très ému j'ai fait mes mes mon
service là-bas et j'étais un petit peu
indiscipliné alors j'ai mis quelques
gens un peu un peu je un peu énervé
j'étais pas je me sentais pas vraiment
militaire on était appelé à cette époque
là et donc je crois que Monsieur le
Maire a été vous avez fait vre service
là-bas aussi je crois j'ai fait mon
service et on a partagé la même prison
parce que j'étais indiscipliné moi aussi
à l'époque voilà accompagné de sa femme
Daniela il découvrira une place à son
nom et une exposition rétrospective des
milliers de fans attendent l'artiste
rester populair malgré son exil aux
États-Unis sa dernière tournée date de
2007 un nouvel album est en préparation
à 70 ans mich californien d'adoption se
fait rare en France car il prend tout
simplement son temps savez la création
ça prend un siècle une seconde et mais
c'est c'est beaucoup de travail en plus
je suis un perfectionniste j'ai un
public de perfectionniste qui qui me
pardonnerit pas d'avoir passé tant de
temps sans le donner quelque chose qui
qui vaille la peine d'attendre l'cale à
bourge ville de la chanson aura été très
brève Michel pa sengouffre dans la
voiture du maire de
en route pour l'hommage que lui rend la
ville auvernat alors good bye l'amiral